which dragon is the biggest a dragon the
size of a house cat versus one the size
of a 747 jumbo jet game of thrones and
house of the dragon have featured both
tiny and huge dragons and i'm here to
show you just how much of a difference
there is between these dragons comparing
the sizes of some of our favorites such
as drogon and balerion the black dread
most of all though i'll show you which
dragon is the biggest out of all of them
we know about and here's a hint it's not
vegar or valeria on the dread
[Music]
one thing to keep in mind with these
size comparisons is that most of the
measurements are estimates from the
television series or based on secondhand
descriptions from a song of ice and fire
or fire and blood so there may be some
slight discrepancies between what we see
in house of the dragon and the rankings
to come anyways let's get into it
starting off with the smallest and one
of the youngest dragons to ever live we
have the last dragon this was the last
dragon alive following the dance of the
dragons and at its death reports claim
it was either the size of a cat or up to
the size of a small horse either way
this dragon was small and sickly with
misshapen wings while its name is not
known this dragon was the last to live
before the birth of daenerys targaryen's
dragons all three of which were quite
small in comparison to older dragons too
up next is viserion the smallest of
daenerys targaryen's dragons named after
her brother viserys he could be
distinguished by his cream and gold
colored scales and his red orange wings
eventually he was killed and became
enslaved by the night king he was also
able to breathe blue fire that was even
capable of melting the wall
slightly larger than vasarion is rhaegal
the second largest of daenerys dragons
named after her brother rhaegar he could
be distinguished by his green and bronze
colored scales and his yellow orange
wings
jon snow rode regal at the battle of
winterfell and fought his undead brother
viserion later rhaegal was killed by a
bolt shot from one of maestro qyburn's
scorpions next up is drogon the largest
of daenerys targaryen's three dragons
named after her late husband khal drogo
drogon was the largest dragon alive at
the time and he grew up to the size of a
small commercial jet he can be
distinguished by his black and red
colored scales and his red black wings
he was also daenerys personal mount with
the deaths of viserion and rhaegal
drogon was the only known living dragon
in existence at the end of game of
thrones
up next is morning a younger dragon
hatched during the dance of the dragons
ridden by lady rayna targaryen morning's
scales were pale pink but with black
horns and crest she was one of only four
dragons to survive the dance of the
dragons and by the time of her death she
was much larger than daenerys
targaryen's dragons next is tyraxis the
dragon bound to prince joffrey velaryon
during the dance of the dragons in the
end it said that taraxis died by
strangling himself with his own chains
while in his lair in the dragon pit the
next largest dragon is airax ridden by
prince lucerus valerion during the dance
of the dragons irax and his rider were
killed by prince aemon targaryen and
veigar in the skies over shipbreaker bay
three days later airax's head washed up
beneath the cliffs at storm's end along
with prince lucerus corpse
up next is vermax known for his hatred
of snow ice and anything cold prince
jakirus valerion rode vermax in battle
and he's well known for his ferocity
during the battle in the golet there
vermax attacked a fleet of ships but he
flew too low and went crashing into the
sea to his death the next largest dragon
is sea smoke written at first by sir
layner velaryon and later by the dragon
seed or illegitimate targaryen adam of
hull after laner's death sea smoke made
his lair on dragonstone for almost a
decade before bonding with adam of hole
sea smoke was later killed in battle by
verma thor when he locked his teeth into
his neck and ripped his head off much
more ferocious than sea smoke tesarion
is the next largest dragon also known as
the blue queen tesarion's wings were a
dark cobalt while her claws crests and
belly scales were the color of bright
copper and she was written by prince
darren targaryen tassirion was later put
down after a battle that left her in
deep pain and too weak to fly up next is
sun fire also known as sunfire the
golden a male dragon ridden by king
aegon targaryen ii in fact the
three-headed dragon in the targaryen
sigil was made golden to honor sunfire
this dragon had golden scales and shot
gold flames and he was known as the most
beautiful dragon to have ever lived
sunfire died after receiving heavy
injuries from battle before refusing to
eat and starving to death
up next is grey ghost the first wild
dragon in our list grey ghost was the
name given to him because of his pale
grey white color and because he mostly
avoided people preferring to feed on
fish
because he never lived in the dragon pit
in king's landing grey ghost was
considerably larger than most dragons
although not larger than the rest of the
dragons in this list the next largest
dragon is quicksilver ridden by king
aenes targaryen the first and his son
prince aegon targaryen for some
reference quicksilver is one quarter the
size of balerion the black dread and he
was killed by the very same dragon
during the battle beneath the god's eye
when belarion ripped quicksilver's
winged from his body causing him to fall
to his death
up next is cyrax featured in house of
the dragon and written by prince
rhaenyra targaryen cyrax was named from
a goddess of valyria of the same name
many of the facts about cyrex's life are
uncertain as well as her death which
there are numerous and contradictory
accounts of how she eventually died
we'll have to wait and see how her story
plays out throughout the series to see
the official account of her life next is
miley's also known as the red queen
written by prince alicia targaryen and
later princess rainey's targaryen melees
had scarlet scales and pink membranes on
her wings for which she received her
nickname at the height of her strength
miley's was known for being one of the
fastest dragons to have ever lived
miley's eventually died in a battle with
veigar and sunfire where she fell to her
death the next largest dragon is karaxis
nicknamed the bloodworm written at first
by prince aemon targaryen and later by
prince daemon targaryen also featured in
house of the dragon although he was only
half the size of the huge veigar
caraxies was fearsome strong and
experienced in battle he was known for
being one of the largest and leanest
dragons alive at the time and he was
twice the size of tesarion up next is
dream fire written by princess reyna
targaryen and later by prince helena
targaryen dreamfire was slender and pale
blue in color with silver and blue wings
she eventually died during the sacking
of the dragon pit when she flew into the
dome above cracking it and causing it to
tumble down killing the dragon slayers
below under tons of broken stone and
rubble next is silver wing written by
queen alisene targaryen and later by olf
white during the dance of the dragons
she is known for being one of the most
docile dragons even acting quite
friendly towards strangers silver wing's
death is unknown and after the dance of
the dragons she lived out the rest of
her days as a wild dragon slightly
larger than silver wing is sheepsteeler
a wild dragon with a taste for mutton
for which he earned his nickname one of
the largest dragons alive at the time
sheep steeler could be identified by his
mud brown color he was eventually
mounted by a young girl named nettles
who made sheep steeler comfortable with
her by giving him a sheep to eat every
morning the next largest dragon is
vermathor nicknamed the bronze fury
written by king jaehaerys targaryen the
first vermathor was three times the size
of tesarion verma thor could be
identified by his bronze color and great
tan wings later he died in a battle with
the dragons tesarion and sea smoke at
five times the size of airax and two
times the size of karaxis next up is
veigar written by queen visenya
targaryen during aegon's conquest it is
said that veigar's breath was so hot
that it could melt a knight's armor and
cook him inside by the time of the dance
of the dragons vegard was the hardened
survivor of a hundred battles had grown
almost as large as balerion and was the
oldest and largest of the dragons in
westeros her roar was so powerful that
it could shake the very foundations of
storm's end
no living dragon could match her for her
size or ferocity the next largest dragon
is maraxis written by queen rhaenys
targaryen during aegon's conquest it's
said that miraxis was large enough to
swallow horses whole and she was
slightly larger than vegar up next is
belarion nicknamed the black dread
written by king aegon targaryen the
first during his conquest other known
writers of valerion were king maegor
targaryen the first princess arya
targaryen and prince viserys targaryen
his wingspan was so large that his
shadow could engulf entire towns when he
passed overhead his teeth were said to
be as long as swords and his mouth was
large enough to swallow a woolly mammoth
hole estimates put his length at over
125 feet long and his wingspan at over
450 feet wide bellerion was one of very
few dragons to die of old age during the
reign of king jahirus targaryen the
first at 208 years old while many people
believe valerion to be the largest
dragon to ever live there is one last
dragon that may be greater in size
the final dragon in this list and the
largest to ever live is a wild dragon
known as the cannibal
this dragon made his lair on dragonstone
even before the targaryens came to
westeros making him at least 243 years
old at the start of the dance of the
dragons the oldest dragon to have ever
lived he was noted to be as large or
larger than bellarion by the time of the
dance of the dragons and he only grew
larger as he aged
estimates put his length at over 175
feet long and his wingspan at over 600
feet wide twice the size of a football
field the cannibal had black scales and
shot black fire and he earned his
nickname because he would feast on
dragon eggs younger dragons and dead
dragons the cannibal was one of the four
dragons that survived the dance of the
dragons but he vanished after the war so
there's a small chance he could still be
alive at the time of game of thrones
since the maximum lifespan of a dragon
is unknown there's potential that the
cannibal continued to grow for hundreds
of years out of sight from any living
person while many of these sizes are
based on secondhand stories and
estimates it's still crazy to see that
at the height of their power dragons
exceeded the size of a jumbo 747 jet and
shrank all the way down to the size of a
house cat it'll be great to see just how
large some of these dragons are in house
of the dragon and i can't wait to see if
we get to see any shots of the cannibal
in live action but please drop your
thoughts in the comment section below
also check out the video on your screen
for some more of my content don't forget
to like and subscribe and thanks for
watching rocket rightly
[Music]